[Music] Check the mic to make
sure you sound right, boy!
Hello!
How much of a fan of the Vision Transformers
are you? Are you happy how Transformers,
initially introduced for text, took over the
state-of-the-art in image classification? Or
are you nostalgically looking back
to Convolutional Neural networks?
Ms. Coffee Bean do not come here
with the nostalgia argument!
ConvNets and their priors are still very
much the kings of their own hill, look:
The Swin Transformers which
are transformers at their core,
do a lot of gymnastics to introduce a
hierarchical processing in transformers;
hierarchical design that ConvNets always had.
If Transformers want to solve not only
holistic tasks like image classification,
but object detection and semantic segmentation
where attention to detail is required (attention…
no pun intended). So if they want to solve these
tasks, transformers need to process smaller
patches than 16 by 16 pixels, like ConvNets do.
So how to compare ConvNets and
Transformers and make it fair?
Sometimes Transformer steal from ConvNets
(I’m looking at you Swin Transformer
with your hierarchical processing),
and the credit for the performance
gain goes to: the Transformer.
But what about reversing the roles:
letting a ConvNet steal from a Transformer?
How many things do we have to add to a ConvNet
to make it as powerful as a Transformer?
Well, if you are interested in these questions,
you’re in luck: What if me and Ms. Coffee
Bean told you that there is a paper which
takes a standard Convolutional Neural Net:
a ResNet and morphs it such that the
design approaches a vision Transformer!
And spoiler: it surpasses the
transformer in terms of performance!
Eeei, Ms. Coffee Bean is
spoiling the surprise here,
so let’s stop her to introduce
our sponsor for today’s video!
Thanks to Weights & Biases for supporting
me and this little Coffee Bean over here!
You do not know who they are? Weights and
Biases is an MLOps platform, helping you and
your team to improve and accelerate the process of
building and maintaining Machine Learning models.
Do you want to track experiments, to save your
model configurations so you can reproduce even
that model which you stashed away months ago
-- which you now maybe want to reproduce,
but cannot remember its settings? Weights
and Biases has got you covered on that front!
Are you training a model and want to find
the right hyperparameter configurations,
but it seems more like alchemy than
science to you? Then let Weights and
Biases’ Sweeps functionality find the optimal
parameters for you during your lunch break.
Don’t worry, Weights & Biases
is not hard to integrate,
it just needs a few lines of code.
And the best bit is yet to come:
This all is for free if it’s meant
for personal use or for academic
teams. So, what are you waiting
for? Check out Weights and Biases!
Now let’s get back to today’s paper making
ConvNets fashionable again for the 2020s:
With this paper, we witness how a
Convolutional Neural Net, or short: a ConvNet,
steals modern training tricks that
Transformers usually benefit from,
to build the ultimate ConvNeXt architecture!
This, ahm... ConvNeXt is super interesting
because by “modernizing” ConvNets step by step,
one can better see where performance can be
gained, like: Is it more the architecture,
is it more the training tricks, is it
more, I don't know, crazy design choices?
And ConvNeXts are competitive with
Transformers not only in image classification,
but also on object detection
and image segmentation where
the Swin Transformer had its reign so far.
Then let’s follow the paper and see:
What is it that ConvNets have that is so
precious and we should keep even in the era
where Transformers take over everything?
Which steps do the authors take to
“modernize” ConvNets into ConvNeXts
and what are the associated performance gains?
What can we learn from all of this?
Feel free to jump around in the video to
watch the parts you are most interested in.
Also note that some of the concepts we
touch upon, we will explain briefly. But
others are left a bit unexplained – as
they would deserve a video on their own.
So, it’s ConvNets versus Transformers today.
The authors introduce the paper by
praising ConvNets – Ms. Coffee Bean,
how else, their agenda is to resurrect
the idea of convolutional networks!
So, the authors start of course, by mentioning how
the deep learning renaissance
was driven by ConvNets in 2012:
The introduction of AlexNet established the
“ImageNet moment” in computer vision and visual
recognition turned from feature engineering to
designing ConvNet architectures that learn their
own features like: VGGNet, Inceptions, ResNet,
DenseNet, MobileNet, EfficientNet, RegNet ...
What do all these networks have in common? Well,
the convolution: a sliding window that processes
the visual input in the same manner. So, the
parameters are shared between image locations.
This is a big plus when bounded by computation.
Convolutions also induce translation
equivariance. Are you not sure what
this means and why the authors used the
word equivariance and not invariance?
Well, then let Ms. Coffee Bean’s past
self explain this in 60 seconds to you:
We have an interesting question on our Quiz,
where the majority is wrong. It’s about
convolutions and the difference
between invariance and equivariance.
Translational or shift invariance
means that irrespectively of the
position of a cat, the output of the
convolution operation is the same
Which it isn’t since the feature map
still reflects the original position.
So this is actually equivariance because
when the position of the cat changes,
the output changes in the
same way, reflecting shift.
And with the sliding kernel,
this is exactly what happens.
So convolutions are not shift
invariant, but equivariant.
If you got this wrong, it’s okay because
these words are used interchangeably in
language (except of highly mathematical contexts).
Please mind that the question
asks about the convolution only.
It was the next day’s trick question
inquiring about the CNN as a whole.
While convolutional layers do not make the
CNN shift invariant but only equivariant,
it takes spatial pooling layers
to make it approximately shift
invariant by pushing information that was
far away, into approximately the same spot.
Okay, we got it. Convolutions are great. But what
about Transformers? Well, after the introduction
of Transformers for text processing in 2017, the
transformer actually had some applications on
image generation or image-text understanding;
applications which went widely unnoticed.
So unnoticed, that today’s paper (like almost
any other paper) does not mention this.
The transformer architecture got properly
noticed by the computer vision community when,
of course, when it was proven to advance
the state-of-the-art on ImageNet.
Okay, then: What is so cool about transformers?
First: The transformer as we know it from
Natural Language Processing (or short NLP) is
more-or-less usable out-of-the-box for images.
Exception is, we cite: “the initial “patchify”
layer, which splits an image into a sequence
of patches” of for example 16 by 16 pixels,
and there we have it: the ViT!
Watch our previous videos on this for context.
ViT’s scaling laws allows to increase the model
size and the size of the training data and it
overcomes ResNets. But ViT’s problems are just
around the corner: without the inductive bias
introduced by sliding windows, the solution
space of transformers is larger than for CNNs.
Just imagine: A CNN, by construction
cannot converge to anything that is not
translational equivariant.
But a Transformer very well can because,
it misses this guiding bias. This is what
we mean when we say the solution
space of Transformers is larger.
The architecture is more flexible
because the solution space is larger.
Therefore, in the case where there is
little training data to find the right
solution in this bigger space, transformers
are dependent on a lot of training tricks,
like heavy data augmentation,
as we have seen with DeiT.
But the biggest problem that transformers
have is everything but ImageNet scenarios:
So, cases where the images are high resolution
and the prediction must be dense: In this case,
patchifying into 16 by 16 pixels might be too
coarse to make right pixel-level predictions.
But if we were to make the patches smaller, this
would quadratically increase the sequence length,
because we would need more of
them to cover the same surface.
And we know that when we increase
the sequence length for transformers,
the compute and memory footprint
increases again quadratically.
To overcome this, Hierarchical
Transformers such as the Swin Transformer
introduce sliding windows again, which makes them
resemble very much with ConvNets in this aspect.
Noting this, the authors cannot help
but ask themselves, what if they would
morph a ConvNet towards a Swin Transformer?
What would we see from this
interpolation to answer the question,
we cite: “How do design decisions in
Transformers impact ConvNet’s performance?”
And imagine, the authors wanted to
know the answer to this so badly,
that they run the according experiments
and write a paper about this!
Then let’s follow their steps of modernizing
ConvNets to make them stylish enough for the
2020s. Since the style of the 2020s
is definitely given by transformers,
we mean that the authors make
ConvNets more transformer-like.
Step 1: Take a ResNet50. The authors also
have experiments with the larger ResNet-200,
but if you want to know about that, read
the paper, more specifically: Appendix C.
You should anyway read the paper
yourself and should not trust a
PhD student and her Coffee Bean to tell you
everything there is to know about a paper.
Or should you?
Okay, we have taken a ResNet50. Now what about
it? Well first, and above all, the authors
train it with similar training techniques
as vision Transformers are trained with:
They use the AdamW optimizer, use more epochs,
heavy data augmentation, regularization.
All of this increases the performance of the
ResNet-50 from 76.1% to 78.8%
on ImageNet Top1 Accuracy.
So wow, lesson learned: I will not forget about
these ingredients when baking my CNN-based models.
The second thing they modernize after they are
done with including the training techniques
is something the authors call the “Macro
Design” of the ResNet. For the stage ratio,
they adjust the number of blocks in
each stage and improve model accuracy.
Then they make the sliding windows in the
ResNet behave more like the patches in vision
transformers: So with a larger kernel size and
with a stride such that the sliding window does
not overlap, this looks already much more like
the non-overlapping patches in the transformer.
This again increases performance,
if only by a little bit.
The third stage adopts the ideas that ResNeXts had
introduced before, namely the idea of Inception
(if you are old enough to remember that) of
splitting, transforming, and merging information.
The keyword here is depthwise
convolutions – a special case of
grouped convolutions – where the number
of groups equals the number of channels.
Important to note (and here we
cite from the paper is, that):
“depthwise convolution is similar to the weighted
sum operation in self-attention, which operates on
a per-channel basis, i.e., [that is] only mixing
information in the spatial dimension.” End quote.
And depthwise convolutions, having
reduced the number of FLOPs,
also reduce the accuracy, but by
simultaneously widening the network,
the performance is substantially
improved. It’s time for the fourth
stage of the whole improvement process,
which is the so-called “inverted bottlenecks”.
We find it a little bit misleading here that
the authors say, that “One important design in
every Transformer block is that it creates
an inverted bottleneck, i.e. [that is],
the hidden dimension of the MLP block is
four times wider than the input dimension.”
Hopefully we do not get something wrong here,
but this is the case for every Swin Transformer in
particular, not for every Transformer in general.
Because yes, in Swin Transformers that work
hierarchically, the outputs of 4 blocks get
concatenated such that in the end, the
hidden dimension increases 4 times.
But in any case, they want
to copy this idea by using a:
we quote “inverted bottleneck design with
an expansion ratio of 4 used in ConvNets”.
And hurray! This increases
performance too, if only by a little.
The fifth stage introduces larger kernel sizes.
This tries to equal the power of vision
transformers that have a global receptive
field and “see” the image at once through
self-attention that spans the whole image.
But Swin Transformers limit the self-attention
window, so if the authors increase
the ResNets window size, then they
should reach the same compromise.
This results in an increase
in performance of … ahm …
nothing. But it’s clear that small
kernel sizes hurt the performance.
And finally, the sixth and final stage
comes with micro design choices, such as:
Replacing the ReLU (Rectified
Linear Unit) activation function
with GELUs (Gaussian Error Linear
Unit) used in BERT or GPT-2 or ViT.
They are using the activation
functions less often,
as transformers also do (in the MLP block only).
And with the same motivation, to do everything
more transformer style, the authors also use
fewer normalization layers because transformers
use them less often than the ResNet as well.
They are replacing Batch Normalization with Layer
Normalization. Short reminder: In BatchNorm,
a mini batch of data that has multiple
examples and features associated to it,
the normalization happens across to the batch
/ sample dimension. The Batch normalisation
effect is that the magnitude of the features
is similar across data samples in the batch.
LayerNorm normalizes across the feature
dimension such that per data sample,
the features have around the same magnitude.
Historically, LayerNorm was something that
worked better for recurrent neural networks,
whereas BatchNorm was mostly used in ConvNets.
And, surprise! All these micro
modifications have a tremendous
impact on performance and by using separate
downsampling layers, this enhanced ResNet
achieves an accuracy of 82.0% ImageNet Top1
Accuracy, exceeding the Swin Transformer!
And these results are comparable, because the Swin
Transformer plays in the same league
in terms of computation and size.
If you’re curious to know how this
fares in the big model league,
you just have to look at
the grey bars in this Figure
where they start from a ResNet 200 and add
all these steps with very similar gains.
Okay, cool. We have seen
steady performance increase
and really impressive numbers and results.
But what are the lessons here with respect to
our ConvNet versus Transformer boxing match?
So, the first lesson here is
that: Not only transformers,
but modernized ConvNets scale too in terms
of size and data – We have not discussed
the data aspect, check out the additional
experiments with more data in the paper.
The second lesson is related to the tasks:
ConvNeXts can compete in object detection
and semantic segmentation with the
Swin Transformer, which we remember
was a hierarchical version of ViT.
Maybe you are wondering what exactly
the novelty of this paper is.
Well, we cite: “It is also worth noting that
none of the design options discussed thus far is
novel—they have all been researched separately,
but not collectively, over the last decade.”
And while the authors here are
genuine convolution advocates,
by reading this paper we must ask ourselves:
What if the bigger lesson of this paper
applies to other architectures, too? What if,
while everyone in NLP suddenly jumped onto
the next stage dominated by transformers,
forgot to stepwise improve RNNs or their Tree-RNNs
or everything that is not fashionable anymore.
So far, we thought that self-attention and the
way that Transformers process information in
parallel highways is the recipe for success.
But this paper suggests that
it is rather the many seemingly
tiny architecture hyperparameters and
not the architecture itself that can
tweak the way to state-of-the-art.
Another thing we wonder, and this is maybe
something only the authors can answer, is whether
the experiments were really conducted in the order
presented in the paper and in this figure here:
It seems more plausible that these
design choices were added in all
possible orders and configurations and that
the authors picked and presented everything
where improvement over improvement can be seen.
Don’t get us wrong, we do not criticise the paper
with this. Ms. Coffee Bean just wants to warn
me that science is not always this
straightforward ascending line to the finish.
And coming back to the contribution and
to the novelty of this paper: Even though
no new design option was presented, it is the
art of putting everything together or rather:
the power of brute-forcing every available option,
that makes this paper bear the fruits it does.
And maybe a tiny critique that almost
any paper in machine learning deserves:
Let’s not forget that papers do the
comparisons they like and suit them best.
Ms. Coffee Bean will leave you to this
tweet, also linked in the description below,
where one of the ViT authors points out that
ConvNeXts were compared only to plain ViT,
while Swin and ConvNexts had heavy augmentation.
Judge for yourself, but also do not
forget to count the number of times
you took the baselines you liked the most.
Ms. Coffee Bean, stop teasing our
audience, let’s rather talk about
how we reached 10k subscribers this
Christmas. Celebration video, when?
Ms. Coffee Bean, Ms. Coffee Bean, come
back! Don’t leave us hanging here!
Okay, bye!